[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 78 sport tous les lundis merci de
nous rejoindre sur TVFI 78 et bonsoir
Anthony bonsoir wilfreine ce soir trois
invités sur le plateau oui tout à fait
au menu de ce 78 sport du 4L Trophy avec
l'équipage 5tinois de retour de ce raide
humanitaire réservé aux étudiants qui
traverse l'Espagne et le Maroc ils sont
d'ailleurs avec nous tous les deux
William udu et Bastien guilbaau bonsoir
à vous deux bonsoir vous nous raconrez
un petit peu tout ça et votre belle
expérience inédite tout à l'heure nous
parlerons aussi de l'cho trail cette
course éch responsable entre la base de
loisirs de 50 ans en ielin Paris qui
peut aller jusqu'à 80 km et le directeur
de course est avec nous sur ce plateau
Hervé pardailler galabrin bonsoir à vous
bonsoir nous parlerons aussi de cette
belle course en deuxième partie
d'émission mais aussi d'aviron nous
avons suivi la reprise de Thomas Barou
le rameur du Cercle Nautique de
Versailles 7e des derniers Jeux
Olympiques de 2012 et puis bien sûr à
tous les résultats du weekend un point
complet à suivre au cours des 26
prochaines minutes on commence par le CL
Trophy alors oui seride humanitaire qui
est réservé aux étudiants et qui
traverse l'Espagne et le Maroc William
hudv et Bastien guilbau vous êtes revenu
il y a quelques jours alors la première
question qui qui me brûle les lèvres
c'est est-ce que la quatelle a tenu le
choc où est-ce que vous êtes rentré à
pied est-ce que vous êtes rentré à pied
exactement effectivement a tenu le choc
donc on a fait 7000 km avec la même
voiture une bonne préparation nous a
assuré un bon raid donc on est revenu
sans et sauf et la voiture aussi je vous
pose cette question puisque quand on
était ven vous voir dans dans votre
garage de préparation le prépa for red
vous avez eu des petits soucis de
châssis un moteur un peu récalcitrant
donc tout tout est tout est bien allé au
final tout est bien allé on a eu
quelques soucis notamment de crevaison
de pneus on a crevé de pneus et on a eu
un petit problème d'allumage sur le
retour en Espagne mais on a mis les
doigts dans dans le camboui puis on a
fini par trrouver la panne ça nous a
pris une heure et pour 04 MIM en fait et
dans ce cas-là on reste serein lorsque
la panne survient qu'on est en plein
désert qu'il faut changer une roue euh
les roues ça va c'est le moins pire
c'est le moins pire on n pas eu de souci
important dans le désert donc tout est
bien allé et le problème d'allumage ça
s'est passé sur le retour en Espagne
donc sur la route on a trouvé on a
trouvé un petit parking surtout que vous
découvriez les preuve puisque c'était
votre premierre aide donc c'est vrai que
en cas de de problème mécanique on peut
peut-être paniquer entre les dunes non
tout à fait c'est vrai que bah à la base
on est parti de rien on y connaissait
rien donc bah comme disait Bastien quand
il a fallu mettre les mains de on y
allit et puis de toute façon c'est en
faisant qu'on apprenant et puis même sur
le même sur le raid on a appris encore
donc tout s'est bien passé au final et
puis pour une première participation
vous finissez 530e sur sur 1446
équipages classés puisque le classement
est pas encore définitif c'est plutôt
une bonne performance on est content de
nous on était pas venu pour ça vraiment
à la base mais c'est vrai que ça fait
plaisir oui l'autre objectif de ce reen
auquel vous participiez le 4L Trophy
c'est l'aspect humanitaire Wilfried et
donc vous aviez beaucoup de de
fournitures paramédical et scolair dans
le dans le petit coffre de de la
catreelle vous avez pu tout donner
comment ça s'est passé justement cet
échange humanitaire donc arrivé à mzuga
pour le le 2è soir le deè soir au Maroc
dans le désert il y avait une cérémonie
de remise de don donc là on s'est vu
remettre nos plus de 50 kg de
fournitures scolaires humanitair et
sportive
paramédical nous avons remis ces dons
donc à des enfants qui avaient été
choisis du Maroc l'organisation du 4
Trophy avait fait une bonne préparation
pour cette cérémonie tout s'est vraiment
bien déroulé donc on en a pris plein les
yeux et en voyant ces montagnes de
fourniture ça nous a fait vraiment chaud
au cœur et alors en terme sportif
qu'est-ce qui a été le le plus dur sur
ce raid le le le maintenir les les temps
entre entre les étapes je sais pas la la
mécanique un petit peu le soir dans les
bivoices euh bah la mécanique du coup on
a pas eu de souci euh ce qui était
surtout dur c'était pas vraiment le
niveau sportif c'était surtout le côté
hygiène on va dire parce que dans le
désert bah on a pas de douche donc bah
faut faire avec et et c'est-à-dire
comment
faire c'est-à-dire qu'on se lave pas
vraiment surtout lingette bon on faut au
mieux avec les moyens qu'on a mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas comme du camping
sauvage voilà c'est ça c'est là que la
cohésion d'équipe est importante si si
vous avec la promiscuité quand on
s'entend pas bien ça doit être ouis ça
doit pas être facile non tout à fait on
a eu la chance de prendre une une douche
au milieu du du raid euh ce qui n'a pas
été le cas pour tous les équipages du 4L
Trophy nous on en a bien profité mais
c'est vrai que pendant toute la durée du
raid c'est assez fastidieux et
contraignant on a l'habitude de bah de
se laver tous les jours ici et là-bas
c'était pas le cas vous parliez des
autres équipages justement sur sur la
route là dans dans les étapes il y a une
solidarité quand il y en a un qui est un
peu au bord de la route on l'aide les
autres s'arrêtent on s'est arrêté de
nombreuses fois pour pour aider bah
toutes les personnes tous les tous les
équipages euh en échange d'un apéro
comme on dit là-bas on en a pas eu
souvent tout ça pour dire que vous avez
pris de nombreuxes apéos c'est
ça on en a pas eu autant qu'on a qu'on a
dépanné les équipages mais bon c'était
vraiment une une action de solidarité de
rencontre aussi de partage d'échang de
pièces de de main d'œuvre de vraiment
que de la solidarité ça fait partie un
peu du cahier des charges aussi de la
compétition on doit s'arrêter un petit
peu sent trader on est vraiment dans
quelque chose de solidaire tout au long
de la compétition ouais c'est pas on
doit s'arrêter mais euh
oua ça fait partie du jeu et puis on est
aussi là pour ça
donc puis c'est si vous aviez un moment
à retenir de de ce de ce reen Bastien ou
William quel serait-il le moment le
moment fort ou ou dur ou le plus heureux
la du premier soir ou la douche ou la
douche ça euh non moi je retire surtout
les les bacs à sable en fait ils
appellent ça les bacs à sable des
portions de de de désert où c'est
vraiment du sable mou où la plupart des
voitures sans sans sable donc là on
descend puis on va pousser à à 5 6 10 10
personnes pousser les quatre ailes et
enfin c'est on est tous ensemble vers un
même but et c'est vraiment sympa quoi et
le le retour à la réalité ici à 50 ans
nel n'est pas trop dur
William il est plus que difficile quand
il faut se remettre dans le bain au
travail à l'école reprendre si je puis
dire la routine c'est vraiment pas
simple on a vécu une histoire une
aventure vraiment fabuleuse qu'on
retiendra tout le long de notre vie ça
c'est certain donc reprendre les
activités quotidiennes c'est vraiment
assez difficile c'est vraiment la la
routine qui revient que c'est vraiment
le mot c'est parce que là-bas tous les
jours c'était céit une nouvelle journée
avec des des nouvelles choses qui qui
allit nous arriver quoi donc et là c'est
ça donne envie de de repartir déjà de de
rechercher un projet pour l'année
prochaine B déjà ça donne envie de
rester là-bas on voulait pas revenir et
ouais repartir bon l'année prochaine moi
je pourrais pas parce que je je des
contraintes scolaires des concours
notamment mais dans 2 ans ouais
peut-être pas le 4 trophi mais on a
d'autres idées pour plus tard très bien
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venus ce soir sur le plateau tfil nous
raconter cette belle expérience et puis
s'il y a d'aventure un autre projet de
de ce type n'hésitez pas on sera on sera
présent juste un dernier petit mot
remercier notre team
78 pas trop non ça va ça passe à
l'antenne c'est mignon jolie petite
ardoise on l' vu on les remercie merci à
tous merci à toutes les personnes qui
nous ont suivi parce que c'est grâce à
elle qu'on est là donc tous les sponsors
et les partenaires nos amis et la
famille la famille voilà et cette
édition qui s'est donc bien passé pour
vous on invite d'ailleurs les autres
étudiants qui voudraient participer ou
qui préparent leur véhiculle pour les
prochaines éditions s'ils sont dans le
département des evelines à se manifester
on va découvrir un personnage à présent
un personnage au vrai sens du terme tout
à fait Wilfrid c'est notre portrait de
la semaine nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de gub Brochot aussi attachant
que que passionné ce cinquantinois a
dévooué une grande partie de sa vie pour
ne pas dire toute sa vie au football et
plus précisément à l'Entente Sportive de
guillancour de 1946 à 2013 l'histoire de
l'ESG à travers son doyen un portrait
réalisé avec Elod moine et Patrick
Jacques dexmud la JOC AG guirou Guill en
cour AG Guy Brochot un même prénom pour
une passion identique du football entre
gub Brochot et le SG l'histoire d'amour
dure depuis
1946 plus d'ailleurs alors âgé de 11 ans
le jeune Guillan courtois découvre le
ballon rond moi j'ai jamais appris à
jouer au foot on a appris par nous-même
on avit pas de chaussur de foot
déjà on jouit avec des des galoches à
Bouaré je sais pas vous avez pas connu
ça à cette époque il n'y a pas assez de
joueurs pour constituer une équipe à 11
dans une seule catégorie le stade
Popesco de guillancour est le terrain de
ses premiers exploits où il commence au
poste de gardien de but avant de passer
défenseur central et il paraîtrait même
qu'il y possède son arbre personnel
lorsqu'il se marie à
veut sacrifier sa passion pour sa vie de
famille moi je veux pas que tu'arrêtte
non parce que B tout ce qu'arrête après
ils prennent une brioche je trouve que
c'est vrai se cétait trop jeune pour
arrêter avant on mangeait jamais le soir
ensemble parce que le lundi il y avait
réunion le mardi il y avait entraînement
le mercredi c'était les petits le jeudi
il y avait entraînement des fois on
mangé le vendredi soir ensemble gu
Brochot a eu tous les costumes à Guill
encours joueur entraîneur bénévole ici
en bleu au côté de l'équipe senior puis
dirigeant en 1972 il participe à la
création du maratra une alliance
d'équipe jeunes venu de tous 50 ans en
Yveline le sous-sol de la maison faisait
alors office de l'avriie du club ici là
j'avais tout un placard avec les
catégories senior enfin tout tout tout
le club tout le club était là quoi et et
le dimanche matin les les joueurs
venaient entre 10h et 11h chercher les
maillots le Doyen a aussi vu son sport
tant aimé
évoluer j'apprécie plus le le le système
de jeu mais ce que j'apprécie pas c'est
le la coopération des joueurs ils ont t
de de distraction autre voyez nous on
arrivait comme je leur disais les gars
oh vous arrivez au vestiaire vous
accrochez vos habits et en même temps
vous accrochz vos soucis et vos comment
dirais-je vos mauvais résultat à l'école
au club tous les enfants connaissent Guy
l'entraînement commence seulement après
avoir salué l'ancien
n dans dans club des personnes
ça
vurs une Tribe va bientôt voir le jour
au stade maurce B le club continue de
grandir et continuera un jour S guoch
mais la relation entre l'homme et leg
restera jamais une histoire d'amour
pleine de fidélité et
d'humilité un personnage attachant vous
avez rencontré cette figure emblématique
de ce club on va continuer cette édition
du 78 sport après le 4L Trophy
d'ailleurs les deux participants de de
sa-quentin qui sont présents et ils sont
restés sur ce plateau on va parler de
l'échotrail à présent oui avec le
directeur de course Hervé pardaill
galabrin bonsoir à vous bonsoir alors
l'coot tril donc c'est une course entre
la base de loisir de 50 Anvin et Paris
la Tour Effel exactement donc qui peut
aller jusqu'à 80 km expliquez-nous en
quoi vraiment précisément ça consiste
cette course les côteril de Paris c'est
finalement l'envie de d'offrir à Paris
sa prochement lieu
un donc une une épreuve sportive une
épreuve verte sur les sentiers de la
région Île-de-France parce qu'on part de
Saint-Quentin en niveline la base de
loisirs de de Saint-Quentin pour arriver
jusqu'à la tour effffel en faisant 0 km
1500 m de dénivelé en traversant trois
départements par qu'on part des ivelines
on traverse les hautes scèes et on
arrive à Paris la Tour Eiffel c'est une
épreuve je dirais pour des adeptes de la
course à pied assez longue c'est on est
même sur 80 km pour cette épreuve là 80
km parce qu'il y a d'autres formats
aussi il y a du 50 il y a de la
randonnée il y a de la marche nordique
mais 80 km ça fait quand même peur hein
il faut faut être aguéri hein pour pour
pour les faire la plupart sont quand
même bien entraînés pour faire 80 km
ceux qui sont pas entraînés généralement
abandonnent au premier au deuxième
ravitaillement qui est Chaville qui fait
combien de kilomères à peu près on est
au 55e génement on a 400
450 150 abandons à peu près sur les 2000
partant au départ de 51 ou parce que
dans le dans le marathon pour avoir une
petite comparaison on parle souvent du
mur des 30 km donc c cette fameuse
distance au-delà duquel le corps est un
peu autonome et l'esprit est un peu
ailleurs là 80 on se dit que c'est juste
infaisable wifried vous seriez prêt à
vous sentez venir non pas du tout 80 800
m vous dire 100 m comme vous voulez mais
c'est aussi pour favoriser la pratique
du sport en général hein je crois ce
cette course alors l'écootraail tout à
fait c'est pour favoriser la pratique du
sport donc c'est un des piliers
justement de l'écotrail donc aussi bien
pour les compétiteurs le samedi par
parce que c'est les épreuves 80 50 30 km
et marchand chronométré le samedi et le
dimanche sport pour tous les randonnées
et la marche nordique non chronométrée
ou le le je dirais l'âge on part de 9
ans jusqu'à 79 ans sur les cotil voz
vous avez trouvé votre format c'est bon
laissez-moi tranquille on pe peut-être
demander à nos invités William et
Bastien vous qui cherchiez à sortir
aussi de la routine maintenant que vous
êtes revenus du 4 Trophy cette
compétition l'cotrail
oui non effectivement on est sportif
mais ant vous voyez je suis pas le seul
merci de me soutenir alors dans échot
tril il y a chcho écologique c'est c'est
un aspect important aussi je crois de
cette course he tout ce qui est
développement durable donc dès la
première année 2008 on a décidé de de
mettre en effet l'accent sur le
développement durable sur cet événement
pour laisser le moins de trace possible
de notre passage parce que c'est quand
même une épreuve de masse donc on a
différentes pratiques donc déjà quand
vous allez chercher votre dossard sur le
village à Paris vous signez une charte
comme quoi vous n'alz pas jeté vos
détritus sur le dans la forêt ou sur les
sentiers donc on va leur donner une
petite pochette déchets qui devront
porter matériel obligatoire et ensuite
sur les ravitaillements c'est
suppressions des gobelets en plastique
donc les les personnes viennent avec
leur propres gobelet leur propre
matériel c'est du matériel obligatoire
et ensuite vous avez des donc une des
bénévoles qui sont là sur les
ravitaillements une centaine qui sont
prévu donc samedi prochain et qui vont
faire de l'animation sur les
ravitaillements uniquement pour le tri
sélectif c'est qu'ils vont être là pour
expliquer au coureur qu'il faut jeter sa
poau de banane dans quel dans quelle
poubelle et ça ça va être quelque chose
de qui va être très marqué cette année
suite à la mais c'est une un point
d'amélioration justement mais prend pas
de pénalité par ex on perd des points
dans la compétition si on respecte pas
cette charte si on ne respecte pas la
charte si on voit un coureur jeter un
détritus une n'importe quoi que ça soit
un gel ou autre chose dans la forêt il
est exclu à vie de la course de
l'éecotrail nous c'est nous c'est une
règle très sanction mais vous allez
surveiller comment parce que vous allez
il y a un coureur il avir des coururs
partout il y a un surveillant derrière
ch quoi pour pour vous rassurer c'est
qu'on a fait donc le nettoyage l'année
dernière du du parcours c'est qu'on
nettoie avant et après ce qui permet de
mesurer le le la pollution finalement
effective parcoureur et on est sur des
des des quantités vraiment très faibles
0,01 g de de par par personne c'est
généralement la perte je dirais d'un
papier par inadvertance donc c'est pas
de de façon je
dirais les gens respectent les règles et
je pense que c'est important sur
justement sur l'écotr qu'on essaie de
faire ce ce se donner ce type de de de
consigne et de règle voilà et alors il y
a aussi l'aspect solidaire puisque bah
par exemple je crois que les les
chaussures un peu délaissées vous les
récupérer et vous vou les donner à une
association qui les qui les retraite en
Afrique c'est ça exactement donc nous
soutenons trois associations donc en
effet Afric run pour les citer qui
finalement récupère les les les
chaussures qui pour une seconde vie tout
simplement donc lors du sur le village
de l'cotrail on récupère les chaussures
et vont être récupéré et envoyé en
Afrique pour des personnes qu'on ont
besoin donc ça c'est la première
association on a d'autres associations
qu'on soutient également les Apprentis
d'Auteuil qui est une association qui
une fondation pour les jeunes en en
difficulté donc ça c'est l'apprentissage
et également le Rire Médecin qui est une
association avec des clownes qui vont
dans les hôpitaux auprès des des enfants
malades h et alors vous attendez à peu
près combien de de coureurs de
participants sur sur ce weekend alors
c'est un weekend où on attend on a à peu
près 10000 inscrits bon alors la météo
on verra en fonction de la météo il y a
toujours un petit peu moins de monde
surtout sur les épreuves pour tous du
dimanche mais on espère être proche des
10000 on peut encore s'inscrire
justement cette semaine ou c'est c'est
déjà trop tard alors pour les courses
chronométrées c'est trop tard mais on
peut encore s'inscrire sur la partie du
dimanche donc toutes les randonné marche
nordique et le 18 km twin santé qui est
une épreuve également qui se court à
deux en binôme h merci beaucoup Hervé
Pader galabin d'être venu ce soir sur le
plateau puis on sera ce weekend donc à
l'chot tril au départ à la base de
loisir de 5quenttins en evveline wilfri
et puis merci également à nos deux
autres invités qui étaient avec nous ce
soir William et Bastien vous avez
participé aux quatell Trophy cette
édition vous êtes classé 500 530e sur
plus de 1400 participants ce qui est pas
mal pour une toute première édition
première participation Antony on
poursuit cette page sport nouveau
reportage oui nous avons suivi cette
semaine la reprise de de Thomas Barou le
le rameur du Cercle Nautique de
Versailles 7e des derniers Jeux
Olympiques de Londres en deux de coupes
son hiver ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
la faute à une préparation tronquée par
les blessures nous a fait nous avons
fait le point sur ses ambitions pour
2013 avec elodim
moine depuis son retour des Jeux
Olympiques Thomas Barou vit un parcours
du combattant victime d'une fracture de
fatigue sur une côte à la reprise de
l'entraînement au mois d'octobre il
écope ensuite d'une tendinite après 6
semaines d'arrêt autant dire que le
rameur versaillais est en manque de
repère je pense que cette blessure elle
vient de l'accumulation de fatigue et de
stress de toute l'année dernière parce
que c'est pas que les jeux la
préparation des Jeux elle a commencé en
octobre 2011 et on na pas arrêté de
toute la saison jusqu'au jeu et même un
petit peu après même si après les jou
effectivement ça s'est un peu calmé
Thomas Barou retrouve enfin la
compétition au championnat de France
indor il y a quelques semaines il se
rassure et décroche une médaille de
bronze à 6 secondes de son meilleur
temps en 6 minutes 19 mais pour faire
partie de l'équipe de France Thomas
dépend aussi de son coéquipier Nicolas
mouton actuellement blessé lui aussi aux
épaules c'est un peu difficile d'avoir
des objectifs
sur les championnats de France parce que
parce qu'on a pas d'entraînement
ensemble donc on sait pas encore où on
en est on sait pas exactement
physiquement où on en est tous les deux
parce que forcément les arrêts pour
blessures sait pas quel impact ça peut
avoir donc pour l'instant on n pas
d'objectif le seul objectif c'est de
faire une performance suffisante pour
être sélectionné en équipe de France et
ensuite ensuite on verra l'équipage
olympique a jusqu'à mi-mai pour
décrocher sa sélection pour les
Championnats d'Europe en Espagne en
attendant l'ingénieur s'adapte à sa
nouvelle notoriété ici au club auprès
des jeunes visiblement c'est un effet
ouais en fait il viennent pas me voir
parce que je pense qu'ils sont un peu
impressionnés mais par contre je ils
connaissent tous mon nom évidemment et
je vois dans leurs yeux dans leur
comportement quand je les croise que
voilà ça leur fait un peu
[Musique]
envie Thomas Barou s'est d'ailleurs
rassuré ce weekend remportant la tête de
rivière interrégionale de K sur le 6000
m ce weekend aussi l'un des maîtres du
taekwendo Mondial venait dispenser ses
conseils lors d'un stage à Montini
lebreteneux l'occasion pour les
combattants cinquantinois de progresser
sur les célèbres techniques de
respiration reportage réalisé avec
Guillaume
camps il n'est pas très grand a l'air
très calme et semble presque inoffensif
pourtant maître Kim yongo est 9e dan de
taekwendo tout simplement ce qui se fait
de mieux au monde alors quand il vient
délivrer ses précieux conseils à Montini
le brotonux les élèves sont
impressionnés c'est la première fois que
je le voyais mais il a de l'énergie
enfin c'est impressionnant on a envie de
faire pareil au niveau de la respiration
comme dit le tan jaune ça apprend à
mieux respirer apprendre donc à être
plus avoir plus d'isance dans les
techniques dans les que ce soit dans les
enchaînements de coup de pied ou dans
les coup de point à 72 ans maître Kim
dégage toujours autant de force qu'étant
jeune et semble en harmonie avec
lui-même lorsqu'il pratique le taekwendo
ancien président de la Fédération
Mondiale a vécu en France pendant une
vingtaine d'années il enseigne l'école
de la vague bleue basée sur la
respiration une méthode d'apprentissage
pleine d'humilité ou la compétition
n'est pas la priorité c'est arrêter
inspiration c'est les Mor parce que
c'est n toujours contrôle
expiration expiré pour énergie
internale n'importe qui pour training
sport am c'est pareil nous c'est ô
inspiration ça c'est pour force maître
kim était aussi présent à Montini le
bretonux ce weekend pour rappeler à ses
élèves qu'un art martial est une
éducation de tous les
jours le 78 sport qui se poursuit sur
notre antenne sur TV fil on passe à
présent au résultats du
[Musique]
weekend 17e de 10 thème journée de
Division d'Honneur Versailles recevait
le Maé ce weekend les coéquipiers de
grégoryi leforce se sont imposés
difficilement de buts à 1 il retrouent
le goût de la victoire après trois
matchs sans succès au classement de de
cette poule de division d'honneur
versaill est dés désormais second avec
43 points et mène la chasse avec le PSG
et Melin derrière l'intouchable leader
Créteil Lusitanos qui a 52 points après
17 journées handbal féminin et cette
victoire de montiny le bretonne 1 oui
17e journée de National 2 les féminines
de Montini recevaient l'èche cap Ferré
au complexe Pierre de Coubertin les
inimontaines se sont imposés 31 buts à
27 grâce notamment à 7 buts de 6 Cécile
Bisel c'est leur troème succès de rang
depuis le début de la saison les
joueuses de Stéphane paysan n'ont jamais
réussi à enchaîner plus de trois
victoires consécutives elles auront une
chance de le faire ce weekend face à
Gani au classement les inontaines
confortent du coup leur 5e place avec 37
points elles ont assez de marge avec ce
qu'il y a derrière et non plus que deux
points de retard par contre sur le 4e
Ici Paris enbal sport américain présent
anon roll roquet cette équipe
incontournable des chocs des lancours
tout à fait 12e journée de National 3
les chocs des lancours recevaient les
Ulis au gymnase de Chastanier les
éenctois entam ce match de la meilleure
des façons en marquant deux premiers
buts coup sur coup dès les premières
minutes respectivement par Renand Caon
et Sébastien Barret les joueurs de
Benjamin Ferrand conservent un peu plus
le palais que leur adversaire et ajoute
un 3oisème but avant la fin de la
première période en seconde mi-temps
c'est une formalité les chocs se salle
l'addition en inscrivant 5 buts de plus
score final 8 buts à 2 au classement
avec cette 4e victoire consécutive les
chocs sont désormais 2e de National 3
avec 21 points à trois longueurs du
leader Camon même s'ils avaient déjà
assuré leur place en play-off lors de la
dernière journée les chocks vont devoir
être performants lors des deux dernières
journées de National 3 où ils
affronteront le leader Camon justement
et leur poursuivant direct auberganville
escrime et puis trappe qui est toujours
au plus haut niveau de très bons
résultats pour le club de trappe oui
lescrimeux espoir que nous avons suivi
en début de saison de trappe Jeromine
npajonga réalise une superbe saison
après avoir terminé 13e en individuel la
tireuse cquentinoise vient de glaner une
médaille de bronze par équipe au
championnat d'Europe junior à Budapest
en Hongrie en battant justement les
Hongroises à domicile 45 touche à 38 une
performance qui devrait lui permettre
d'obtenir sa sélection pour les
championnats du monde une sélection qui
devrait tomber dans les tous prochains
jours et alors où en est-on de ce
dossier du
pariss-germain le futur candéloge va-il
s'installer oui un dossier qui traîne et
beaucoup beaucoup hein dans un dans un
entretien accordé au Parisien vendredi
dernier le président du parisint-germain
nasifi a confirmé vouloir retenir le
choix d'ici 2 à 3 mois de de ce nouveau
centre d'entraînement pour pour le pour
le club de la capitale le président
qatari a donné toutefois un petit indice
le club veut être propriétaire de ces
terrains ce qui ne signifie que ce ne
sera pas Saint-Germain en lait et donc
du coup Montini breteneux et poissi
tiennent la corde et puis il y a eu ces
rumeurs autour de la ville de Versailles
aussi même si ça a été démenti dans un
premier temps en tout cas jusqu'à
présent par la municipalité on verra
bien d'ici d'ici à cet été on espère
donner l'information dans cette édition
du 78 sport qui est quasiment terminé
pour aujourd'hui une petite info une
toute dernière ou plutôt une tendance
c'est c'est la danse à la mode c'est le
harlemche le principe est très simple on
danse de façon complètement loufuck et
déguisé sur une un morceau de de musique
électronique d'un DJ américain et bien
les clubs ivinois s'y mettent voici la
danse du club de RMI de manthe attention
ça vaut le coup
d'œil
[Musique]
con los
terroristas
[Musique]
E
voilà le harlemsake qui à la mode mais
ça passe un petit peu de mode et puis ça
peut être dangereux aussi he du côté de
l'Australie 15 mineur d'une compagnie
australienne de service miniier licencié
pour avoir exécuté cette version
souterraine du unlemcheake sur leur lieu
de travail et pour l'avoir diffusé sur
Internet et voilà pourquoi nous n'en
ferons pas sur ce plateau ce soir parce
qu'on tient à nos emplois n'hésitez pas
à commenter ce 78 sport sur les réseaux
sociaux qui qui touche à sa fin à lundi
prochain bonne
soirée
[Musique]
for